they say beauty is in the eye of the
beholder
but in the world of augmented reality
however
anything goes is this virtual lens a bit
of fun
or are they the ultimate art of
deception i only use filters when i
don't have makeup on
this is a video of me i think the filter
just helps you
you don't need to use any filters i
rarely take a picture without them
a survey by girl guiding found more than
a third of girls and young women refused
to post selfies online without a filter
hello thank you for calling quite a
beauty huda katan founder of the billion
dollar company huda beauty
has had enough she's always been open to
her 70 million online following about
the cosmetic work she's had done
now she wants the public brands and
influencers to own up
and be honest about when they've used
filters and editing
that pressure of these perfect images
that are
so far again unattainable has also
created this this sense of unhappiness
and this sense of incompleteness you
know where we are not
complete without the editing i see my
daughter
she thinks it's normal to only use
filters
and i don't like that is she growing i
grew up in a world where
people are honest like could that
possibly happen is that too much to ask
apps like facetune snapchat and
instagram have changed the game
preset filters like this one means that
within a matter of
seconds i can radically change my
appearance so if we look at this
filter over here for example my skin is
tanned it's flawless
i've got high cheekbones my lips are
huge and also
i've got really quite cat-like eyes
people used to bring in pictures of
their favorite hollywood stars but
now they're bringing pictures with
snapchat filters
dr t jean easter is a cosmetic
reconstruction doctor from london
he says patients often come in wanting
to look exactly like their filtered
pictures and he's seen a sharp rise
during the pandemic
that he's coined a zoom boom a lot of
patients now are analyzing what they
look like on those platforms
similar to what they did on social media
platforms this has caused many
insecurities
i have to tell them no about a fifth of
my list i have to say that they're not
suitable for treatment
it's usually down to body dysmorphia of
how they see themselves
and with those type of patients
treatment is not the way forward
the success of makeup artist sasha
pilari's recent filter drop campaign
means companies and celebrities may be
banned if they exaggerate the product
being advertised
the pandemic has forced us to get used
to the new normal
but is it time maybe to embrace our
normality saber chowdhury sky news